hey guys what's up this is andrew from
consensus.com so in this video guys i
want to make a full update on the
bitcoin because we have some nice things
happening so i want to show you what i
think might happen let's get into it
[Music]
and yes so i've done a video on bitcoin
last week so i told you guys there are a
few different scenarios so let me show
you again this was my counting guys i'm
here in the weekly time frame it's a
very long term counting and
the question i had was are we still in
this fifth wave that is in red here or
is it complete okay
if it's complete
then we're gonna correct for one year if
it's not complete then the correction
that is lasting
for the past two three months might be
the end of the very cycle and we might
start a new cycle all right so i think
unfortunately that it's complete so this
is my view let me show you how it would
look so
here you have the different scenarios so
let me
put back this is not good bam bam this
is not a giant abc attack one two three
four
five okay the fifth is here this is a
force
okay the fifth is here so i think we are
like that guys so i think we are in the
a wave that the b wave is on the way and
that the c wave would come probably not
to 15 000
or maybe 27k okay
so i give this correction a few more
months at least two to six more months
of correction on the bitcoin and then
only i think we'll go higher but to be
honest i don't know okay so first i
think we are starting a new buddhist
cycle that will last at least a few
weeks
so i'm gonna show you why i think so i'm
going to show you the levels we might go
to if this is the case i will also show
you what can signal that actually it's
not only a few weeks rally but maybe
longer and i will of course show you
guys what makes me think that we entered
a two weeks
or maybe more
bullish cycle so to do that i'm gonna
zoom in i'm gonna go on the daily
timeframe
and i'm gonna analyze what is happening
here all right so as i showed you guys i
have different accountings that both fit
the price action
here i'm on a logarithmic scale okay
because i like to analyze bitcoin using
the logarithmic scale it gives it's
giving me better reactions when i use my
trend lines and it's giving me a better
view but on the short term as you can
see if i put my trend line here
okay i have one this is not through the
reaction three reactions and we are
coming here okay so
this one line is giving me some
resistance but actually if you go on a
regular scale it's feeling better why
let me show you why guys it's very
important to understand that because you
never know what scale to use right
usually on assets that move more than
fifty percent in one year which is the
case for bitcoin we're talking about
hundred two hundred percent move in one
year the logarithmic scale is better
this one but on short term moves look
here i have one reaction two reactions
using the regular scale then here it's
giving me a third reaction which is
already the confirmation and it gets
rejected brutally which is already the
confirmation that most traders are
paying attention to the streamline okay
guys
then we get strongly rejected and then
we come back to it and look guys what
happens here
we get one more reaction here
on the first of february on this
trendline and i was a seller here
personally i sold a little bit of my
position around 39 000
and right now
then we got we got another reaction guys
i'm just trying to show you guys here
that this trend line is very visible by
many traders and that it makes it
resistance level that once broken
properly with a nice good and reliable
breakout will deliver a continuation
move on the upside all right this is
what i'm trying to show you here
so here then another reaction
and then look at the breakout let's go
to hourly timeframe it's very visible
so let me adjust a little bit my trend
line because i want to match
the most recent past is the most
important all right guys
so bam here i'm matching exactly those
levels i mean almost exactly and look
how many reactions one two three four
okay we can take those into account i
don't know if we can take it into
account but almost all right and here
one two three and then
where is the breakout guys
the breakout happens here
and the volume increase of course is on
the breakout look at this bar this is
the volume increase so what is this
telling me i'm here on an hourly time
frame which is of course too short to
analyze a three month correction but on
the hourly timeframe i can see that this
level here
was the level where bulls got massively
in okay because on the bitcoin you often
have traps traps that are created by
wells who trap investors retail
investors on purpose they know retail
investors are here they're going to buy
and they're going to trap them
and sell strongly afterwards so then you
would have for example a strong bullish
candle a lot of stop losses here which
would generate a volume but not such a
big volume all right this volume is too
big
look at the past before to be a volume
that is only coming from stop losses so
in here we have natural bias and then
usually you would have a red candle
following right after because then they
trap you all right and they sell they
don't want the price action to stay high
too long because this would mean this
would create a signal for many buyers
like myself i was waiting until this
morning before getting in i'm gonna get
in right now i'm going to show you how
for this reason whenever the breakout
lasts long enough it will create a
signal that uh will
very likely be followed by more
investors so here let me go back on a
daily timeframe
okay and let's analyze this bracket by
the way guys i built the course it's
been like six months i'm working on that
guys almost full time it's gonna be
amazing i'm almost finished i'm
recording the last videos i have already
written the whole pdf and i'm gonna give
you guys a full step-by-step method to
trade breakouts i'm gonna explain how to
use volume how to use volatility how to
use momentum i'm gonna show you the
different entry methods that we can use
and basically this method guys would be
something that you can refer to anytime
that you see this kind of breakout so i
want to here to analyze that with you to
show you how actually i see things by
the way for those who are interested
just click on the link in the
description of this video you're going
to arrive on the elliott wave landing
page but you can subscribe to that at
least i have your email and it will be
in the list whenever i will release my
course and so you're going to be able to
get a massive discount guys for those
who are interested so let me come back
to the bitcoin so here i was saying we
have
this
nice consideration it's not nice
actually it's a consideration we saw on
the hourly timeframe that many traders
were around this trend line so we have a
consideration but guys it's not a very
nice consideration again i could show
you in the past let me go in another
chat all right look at that guys this is
all right this is what i'm gonna teach
you in my course guys i'm gonna teach
you how to trade the triangle how to
trade a wedge how to trade a reversal
pattern a reversal breakout how to trade
a continuation breakout i'm going to
show you how to avoid fake outs
all the different patterns the cup and
handle the zigzag and here you have many
many breakouts guys and i've been going
through that for the past couple of
weeks when i record these videos and i
studied bitcoin a lot
and i can tell you that this breakout is
good but compared to for example here
look how was the consideration very nice
and very long we're talking about two
three weeks consideration before this
huge move up right here it's been only
one week we are consolidating on low
volume to me this breakout is not
perfect but it's definitely tradable so
i'm not going to show you the past i'm
going to show you what i think might
happen in the future guys so
we said we have a good breakout because
we have a volume increase we have a
small consolidation just before that is
showing us that this trend line is
reliable it's visible followed by all
the trailers we have a bullish regular
divergence here the macd is going higher
as you can see the macd is the blue
curve the price action is going lower
which is showing us guys that we have
the bears are out of steam so whenever
you have a regular divergence combined
with the breakout you have a bullish
signal all right so momentum is good we
are above the 20-day moving average
which is good we have a volume increase
we have a small consolidation that
happened before the breakout on low
volume which showing us that we have
balance between bulls and bears and you
need to have this balance before a
sustainable reversal can happen okay i'm
going to show you then the targets that
are not very high but it's still a
reversal that might give us a good
bullish signal for the coming weeks okay
volume ejected volatility yeah and the
problem i have is that the voice you see
we like to see bollinger bands very
tight guys before breakout look here how
tight they were and you can go in the
past and check it guys this is what i'm
showing you my course they're very tight
everywhere every time before a breakout
and here they're not very tight guys
okay so that's
telling me that this breakout is not
perfect i give it a grade like i said
guys on my discord for those who are
there i should use my trades guys that
i'm going to do today and i give it a 7
on 10 grade which means there is a 30
chance to me we fake out so it's not a
perfect breakout but it's good enough
for me to get in once again because i
have a big volume because i have a
trendline very visible i have a move
that closed at the top of the day guys
which is very good it means it shows
that bulls were in full control there
were there was not any attack of bears
like whales who could have actually
tried to trap investors so maybe they're
going to do it do that later you know
probably by the way but not right now
okay so i think that right now bears
will slowly let it go and booze will
take back confidence
and we'll start to be biased but
as the consolidation is small guys all
right this consolation is not big it's a
small consolidation and whenever the
consideration is small a retest is
likely to happen and i'm explaining that
guys and i'm giving you all the features
of what makes a re-test more likely to
happen and a small consideration is one
of them so in this situation we're gonna
use fibs to enter
so we measured the last move up guys and
we check where the field ratios are all
right and we try to make it in line with
the moving average and with the trend
and we test so here the moving average
the 20 day moving average is at 38
500 and the trend line re-tests
is at
it depends when it happens
but around here i would say okay so
those are buying levels and i'm just
checking that they're in line with fib
ratios that are between 38.2 and 61.8
this is the buying area guys okay
so
those are my orders i'm not using stop
loss on bitcoin because i don't want to
get trapped but it's better to have
mental stop-loss so that i'm going to go
and sell manually
around 35 okay so this is my
trade guys i'm sharing it with you
and bam this is what i'm going to do
today okay guys i'm going to be a buyer
30 even higher 39 okay i don't want to
miss it
39
i'm gonna buy more a bit lower and i'm
gonna stop everything here so guys i've
just shown you a little example of how
to trade bitcoin let's see if i am
correct or not then
as i think we're going to be wave so i
associate the breakout technique that i
have here with my elliott wave counting
that is telling me that we are probably
in a b wave and then i'm checking b
waves where can they go i have my
natural resistance levels that are
around 44 and 52 i check the feed ratios
fib ratios are the b waves usually go to
the 38.2 so 47 000 guys it's quite high
i will still take profit a little bit at
44 so basically between 44
and it can even go higher guys it can go
to 55 i don't see a bitcoin at 55 but i
mean if you use fibs it could go there
strong b waves go to the 61.8 percent so
let's see
i personally will take profits between
44 and 52 and i'm gonna get ready for a
potential c wave and once again if we
have here extremely high volume involved
during this b wave as i showed you guys
go check the video i posted last week if
we have very high volume here
okay during this b wave like for the
coming month all right like we had
before look in the past how high were
the volume during moves up if we have
that it will tell me that discounting
might be wrong and that the other one
might be correct and that we might
already be in a one two three four five
that goes to hundred thousand but this
is not my preference tonight for now and
i'm going to keep an eye on the volume
on the amplitude of the moves and on
every indicator related to volatility
volume and momentum to see if the
scenario is the one that is likely to
happen so that's it for me guys i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to show see
you guys